[Música]
só hoje vou ensinar o que fazer
estava faltando aqui parece um caso
ainda vai até agora todos os vídeos que
eu vi pessoas fazerem a fazer estão
dentro não estava contente nem se
mostrar como é feito com quatro enquanto
o avião ou mais 5 mac e deixa
desconfiado mas como não foi fato
negócio só não fazer teste não foi o
fato de termos um piloto e óbvios e não
gosta porque eu não vou encontrar o
senhor vai me ligar e fazer enquanto não
via um teste e pronto em um futuro
distante e fazendo da geórgia têm
chegado mesmo a maneira correta de um
vai voar
vocês viram no início e futuramente
poderão ver no final sabe vocês têm que
olhar a mãe do brasil foram mais a fazer
com que essa aliança seja mais pesado
que os outros pensem o mesmo isto é uma
folha mas tem de ter relação muito de
asas
portanto fui até agora fazendo uma linha
a nossa aqui estudando onde você pode
usar uma raiva na liga o técnico vai à
morte
eu não faço deste avião ser mais pesado
acho que o tempo ou seja mais 15 se você
gosta que as linhas ficam muito tempo lá
no ar
acho o outro lado como é mais pesado
você não vai conseguir lançar mais alta
e com velocidade maior para a conquista
em ilhéus que você quer alcançar uma
distância maior de ofertas criam é o
alcance do sinal e praticamente apa
[Música]
veja aqui tem ainda os 50 livre
eu não estava à espera que estejam
bastante e dois aviões foi experimentar
o último time foi o início e final
no final eu consegui fazer um teste com
um boné e leva a mulher a entregar
fazendo outro ali mas na batalha muito
bem meus amigos corinthians não vou nem
tanto mas acho que usar o teste leva
caxias que não fiz mais de 7 enquanto
meu livro chove muito então é complicado
eu já estava muito próximo então escolha
aqui muitas pessoas dólar o que nós
vamos fazer não fizerem este bar
o outro avião não vai embora da fazenda
assim essa menina vai ser paralela extra
por caso não seja problema vai parar o
avião vai ter provocado 30 mil não vou
mais de 23 metros
vejo aqui em casa
lembrou que mesmo prestar
[Música]
a gente fica aqui uma pequena distância
em que não há celebração da alegada
lesão grave que já fica aqui criado num
nem fecha mas já que a distância daqui
tem que ser igual aqui é isto faz com
que muitas pessoas não conseguiu fazer o
avião direto feita a primeira razão é só
sobre o corpo em cima da outra
veja aqui a estratégia é usada em que
você está em paralelo e assim ao passar
pelo vento vai causar atrito mas caso
não estejam sempre lado avançaram para
31 mil não vai embora pois segundo ele a
gente não consegue fazer podiam ser team
na hora de mandar você tem que mandar
bem lá em cima é muito bem que você não
vai conseguir fazer esta embora ou
qualquer outro bem estar assim uma
princesa pessoal então mesmo sem bem
limpa opção de festa deputado e até o
próximo
[Música]